[Music]
how's this dude still alive he's not a
neuro dude this is a man by Handsome
Charlie I'm Lester here we on the set of
Avengers I've been lucky enough along
with other guardians of the galaxy to
join up with the Avengers and be here
and get an opportunity to save the world
is in my Choong Avenger now as well I
don't know maybe like a third-string
Avenger yeah was one of the founding
members yeah thank you so it's you know
out of all the people that I've had the
good fortune to work with these two
particular guys and the triumvirate that
we formed together
it's very special friendship and
decade-plus of time together
go team yeah
it's been this witnessing of like
people's lives growing and changing it's
been a really cool experience working
with Lizzy has been really really
awesome and I think there is something
very powerful about being able to play
women who do heroic things and those
women are so awesome so we've had a
really good time
hanging out with everyone on the set is
one of the best parts of this job
actually because it does have this kind
of large extended family feel I had a
bit of a bucket of someone's worth
practice I thought he'd be good fun I'm
proven completely wrong in that front he
was odd Lluis and boring and not
particularly funny
well at first Blanche it's hard to know
what to make a Cumberbatch and then the
more time I spent with him on and off
set I just kind of infatuated with this
guy I was thinking you know the journey
that Robert Downey jr. is made he's the
Godfather of all this is literally been
the adventure of a lifetime I get a
little misty thinking about it so you
know I lucked out
[Music]